les associations humanitaires
s'inquiètent de la baisse des dons
depuis le début de cette année les
français sont ils vraiment moins
généreux la charité c'était mieux avant
c'est plus compliqué
[Musique]
d'abord notons que la charité est
difficile à chiffrer précisément en
france ce n'est que depuis les années 90
après l'instauration de la réduction
fiscale en faveur du don qu'il est
possible de quantifier une partie de la
générosité des français
alors depuis 1991 la totalité des dons
déclarés aux impôts par les français a
bien augmenté passant en 24 ans de 630
millions d'euros à 2 milliards six cent
vingt millions d'euros soit 4 fois peu
et en matière de charité chacun sa cause
on donne pour les restos du coeur le
secours catholique et pourquoi pourquoi
pour aider la recherche contre le cancer
mes médecins sans frontières vous donnez
à qui bon bah je ne sais pas tout dépend
de la pancarte et de répandre la
personne qui me le demandent
le dispositif fiscal pour inciter l'aide
aux personnes défavorisées peut
expliquer la générosité croissante des
français
la loi votée en 1988 ap les amendements
coolus et en hommage à l'artiste qui
dans son combat contre la misère avait
défendu cette idée il faut changer cet
article 238 bis du code général des
impôts pour qu'il favorise le don que
chacun chacun qu'ils avaient l'intention
puisse donner ce que ça lui coûte
seulement à lui quoi c'est à dire qu'il
utilise une partie de l'argent qui leur
est donné à l'état pour venir en aide à
une association de son choix et les
gouvernements successifs continueront
d'encourager la philanthropie
d'abord fixée à 40 % le taux de
réduction fiscale pour les dons n'a
cessé d'augmenter
une disposition votée cette fois en
juillet nous permet de déduire des 1 co
60 % des dons faits aux associations et
aux fondations à la condition de ne pas
dépasser 20 % de son revenu imposable
aujourd'hui le taux de la réduction
fiscale pour certains dons s'élève à 75%
par exemple si vous donnez 100 euros à
une association comme la croix rouge ou
les restos du coeur vous ne payez en
fait que 25 euros
un argument de poids pour les donateurs
si j'avais beaucoup d'argent je pense
que je donnerai sans compter après mon
nom peut donner un peu plus parce qu'on
sait que derrière c'est un peu récupéré
sur les impôts si les chiffres des
impôts sont de bons indicateurs pour
mesurer la générosité des français ils
ne prennent pas en compte les foyers non
imposables qui pourtant font aussi
partie des donateurs
selon une enquête menée par le réseau
associatif recherches et solidarités
il existe donc une grande différence
entre les dons déclarés 2,6 milliards
d'euros en 2015 et les dons réel qui
s'élèverait en réalité à plus de 4
milliards d'euros
[Musique]